Hey, in this video, we're gonna talk about the difference
between chat models and reasoning models.
We'll learn about why you should use different types
of models depending upon the task.
So firstly, chat models.
If you've ever used something like ChatGPT,
then you've used a chat model.
A chat model is basically a large language model
that uses a sequence of messages in a message history
as inputs and returns messages as outputs.
On the left here, you can see we've got
what is digital marketing and that is a user message.
You can also see that we've got a response from OpenAI.
That is an AI message.
There are three different types of messages
that generally chat models expose.
There's the developer system message.
There's the user messages,
which are the messages that you would generally type.
And then there's the AI messages
that come back from a chat model.
There are lots of large language model providers
to choose from.
For example, we have OpenAI with their GPT-X series.
We also have Anthropic,
which offers Claude Sonnet and Claude Opus models.
There is also Meta with their free open source models,
which are the Llama models.
There is also Google Gemini.
They have both a Google Gemini Pro
and a Google Gemini Flash series of models.
There's Mistral and many more.
Some of the characteristics that you'll find
with chat models is that they are actually very quick.
They have low latency.
These models respond quickly
and often stream the tokens to you word by word.
They're very good in terms of the reason capabilities.
For example, Claude or GPT-4O are able to solve
easy to medium difficulty tasks.
Reasoning models are a newer type of model
that uses something called test time compute scaling.
And basically, you can think of test time compute scaling
as basically allocating more time
to thinking and reasoning
before returning the result or the response.
So in general, these models take a lot longer
because they're actually allocating time at execution
to think through the problem rationally
and then coming up with an overall solution.
Let's have a look at this
so we can see that it's got multiple turns
and it has a bit of reasoning.
That output then goes into the second turn
which then has some input
and then that goes into the reasoning
which then produces an output.
So you can see it's a multi-turn experience
and basically that means that it's got more thinking time.
So when you ask it a question,
we'll allocate more time
before actually responding to you or your query.
So the kind of characteristics you'll get
when you're using a reasoning model is increased latency.
Now, OpenAI, which have released GPT-5
have two modes for using this.
There is the fast mode and there is the thinking mode.
You'll find that if you use the thinking mode,
it has additional latency.
It takes longer to come back
and longer for you to get that response.
Now, due to this test time compute reasoning,
these models will definitely outperform chat models.
If you have a very hard problem
or you're not sure
or you don't mind suffering
with some additional time for the response to come back,
if you want to make sure
and it's a very important piece of work,
definitely use a reasoning model.
They have more time that they spend on the problem
and they will give you more accurate results.
Realize that there's always a trade-off here
and you are spending longer waiting for the AI model
to get back to you.
Here are some examples of when you should use
a chat model versus a reasoning model.
So for example, when we're doing content,
quick emails and posts,
but when we might use a reasoning model
is technical documentation or research analysis.
For example, if we look at problem solving,
basic calculations or simple Q&A,
but if we were using a reasoning model,
maybe we'd use that for multi-step debugging.
Okay, so you now know the difference
between a chat model and a reasoning model.
Let's have a look at how we can do this
inside of OpenAI.
Go to chatgbt.com
and then if you go and click in the top left,
you can see that we have the option to use GPT-5.
We've either auto fast thinking
or if you even upgrade even further,
you can get a pro,
which is research grade intelligence.
You can see that auto will basically do model routing
where look at your query and decide,
is it gonna be using a fast inference model,
so a chat model,
and also we have the option to do thinking.
So if I say thinking,
and then what we can type is what is data science?
And then what you'll see is
when we then submit our query,
you can see that chatgbt is thinking.
If you click on the thinking,
you'll see that you can actually see
the thoughts and the reasoning tokens
that chatgbt decided to do.
Then we get our response.
So we had to wait seven seconds
for the thinking model
to come back with a response for us.
If we contrast this with fast
and I go and load a fast model,
and then I'm gonna keep in the same conversation
and say what is data science?
You'll now see that we don't have any thinking tokens.
We basically get an immediate response.
However, the model isn't thinking about
how best to service our query.
So that is how you can switch.
Now, obviously, if you want,
you can stick on auto mode,
which will look at how complicated your query is,
and it will decide whether to use a fast model
or whether to use a thinking-based reasoning model.
For best practices,
I would recommend for tasks that require increased accuracy,
or you must make sure that the error is less,
use reasoning models.
For tasks such as content generation or copywriting,
you can use a smaller chat model.
Reasoning models also take time to respond.
So you can also have a reasoning model
working on a task for a couple of minutes
whilst you're also using Claude or GPT-40 alongside that.
So don't wait two to three minutes
for the task to complete.
Go and work on another task
whilst you're waiting for the reasoning model
to get back to you.
In the next section of the course,
we'll look at how you can use standard practices
such as list generation, sentiment analysis,
and writing clean and clear instruction
to make sure that you get the most out of these models.